I studied the Korean War it was the only
war in which no American prisoner ever
escaped from a minimum security Camp you
see they have a way of checking you out
by asking you questions about your life
what are you going to do when you get
back how much money do you need if you
said I just want to be happy I just want
peace the mind says piece of pie piece
of bread piece of what you need to take
the generalities and give them
specificity they took the people with no
goals and called them purposeless they
put them in minimum security code
minimum security Camp country clubs the
death rate went up disease rate was up
in the minimum security camp with more
food and comfort in the maximum security
Camp they put people at Deep beliefs
people who wanted to get home people who
were going for Freedom who knew how much
money we need what kind of goals we
believe in and they classified them as
dangerous because they were leaders
people always follow someone who knows
where they're going